[Music]
the
look at this welcome to Norway you're
Americans yeah hi hello I can't believe
we inherited this place middle of
[Music]
nowhere there's something in the barn
what do you mean
something
so what do you think happened probably
some kids woo that's a barn elf are they
real yes first off the baral doesn't
like changes to the farm that looks good
secondly he hates bright artificial
light what do you think and he hates L
[Music]
moist motion activator no
this is really
bad you're in Norway now okay nothing
bad ever happens
here what's going on here we are under
attack where's your gun I don't have a
gun what this isn't Detroit
bill
what on Earth did you do to make them so
mad we broke all the
[Applause]
rules what are you going to do about it
I'm going to swipe this area for
fingerprints and then I'll call the
forensics and
uh